well our Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
pushing for a breakthrough in D
nuclearization talks with North Korea
the Secretary of State is meeting with
top officials in the Hermit Kingdom but
fresh questions are now being raised
about its commitment to actually ditch
their nuclear weapons there are new
reports today that the Hermit Kingdom is
working on a submarine capable of firing
nuclear-armed missiles not a great sign
joining us now to analyze is Gordon
Chang author of nuclear showdown North
Korea takes on the world along with
David to Furi a former Department
official during the Obama administration
thank you both for being here Gordon
I'll start with you you say they've got
one shot which the president has said
what has to happen on this trip for the
Secretary of State I think the Secretary
of State needs to come back with a
written commitment from Kim saying look
giving up nukes giving up missiles going
to dismantle the weapons our
infrastructure and agree to the most
intrusive inspections regime on earth we
need this now because we've seen all
these reports not only the ones about
the submarines but also the increased
production of fissile material yeah
working on their plutonium reactor which
has no peaceful purposes all the rest of
it
so we need to know where Kim stands
David you know the last deal we struck
the Iran deal left a bad taste in a lot
of our mouths what can be done here to
avoid the pitfalls in my opinion of that
deal well you know Pete I agree with
Gordon
Pompeyo has the hard work now of ironing
out the details of the agreement in the
summit to denuclearize that means he has
to have a list of things that North
Korea is going to do to denuclearize and
those have to be things that we can
prove are happening otherwise president
Trump and Pompeyo cannot say that this
is a success I'm hopeful I'm optimistic
but it means getting kim jeong-hoon to
really lock down on certain things he's
going to do and then having him do those
things yes you know Gordon David raises
a good point he they got to do it what
happens if because we've seen these
reports in the news media they're still
developing this they're still doing that
what if we sign a great deal Pompeo
leaves and then North Korea - three
weeks from out it's clear that there
cheating what do we do next I think we
go back to the maximum pressure campaign
which is way Kim got to the bargaining
table in the first place so for instance
that means tightening sanctions on North
Korea but more important going after
North Korea's major power sponsors the
Russians and the Chinese China being
helpful right now
no and president Trump actually
intimated that when he said that after
that second summit between Kim and C
Jinping the Chinese ruler that the North
Korean attitude became much more
difficult you know China has been
busting sanctions been very open about
it Chinese banks have continued to
launder money for the North Koreans and
we have not imposed the costs on Beijing
and we got to do that absolutely David
from the view of someone who worked for
the Obama administration do you feel
like having folks that North Korea is
worried about whether it's John Bolton
there Mike Pompeo does that help at the
table for them to realize if they don't
do it they might see even more than
maximum pressure you know I worked on
the Obama campaign I'm not sure if that
helps or not that may have gotten us to
this point especially some of the
rhetoric by Trump and Pompeyo is real
shuttle diplomacy which has been really
effective but right now the only thing
that's going to result in actual
progress is having North Korea actually
demonstrate that it's pulling out of
certain things now we heard news to this
week that there's satellite imagery
showing that North Korea is still using
some of the nuclear sites it's still
actively using them that's a bad sign
like the submarine example that you gave
as well so this is the hard work that
Pompeo has to do absolutely the one of
the things David just referred to is
North South Korean lawmakers said that
it looks like they're developing a new
submarine capable of launching
nuclear-armed ballistic missiles is that
a hedge in case this doesn't work Gordon
or is this a thumbing of the nose well I
think it's a thumbing of the nose the
North Koreans have been working on
missiles launched from submarines for a
very long time they actually launched a
missile from under the surface of the
Sea of Japan August 24 2016 they have
the Russian technology to do this so
this has been a long-term project of
theirs I think they're now they're just
accelerating what they've done before
David I appreciate your fair-mindedness
on this as someone who's been a bit had
to be defensive about certain things as
you look at the prospects of
this deal because we all want it to work
is it an over 50% chance that it happens
are you pessimistic I think it's a 50%
chance that this is going to move
forward in a productive way but I think
it's real high stakes for the Trump
administration because this is now their
number one foreign policy objective and
they don't have much else to show on the
foreign policy front other than North
Korea which could be fantastic if North
Korea really does take legitimate
identifiable steps to denuclearize 50%
and if the flip side is war or the
threat of war you certainly don't want
that side either appreciate you're both
great great insights this evening